If you're planning to
watch the upcoming
Super Bowl,
you'll likely see a few ads about Jesus.
CNN's Tom Foreman looks at
who is behind the He Gets US campaign
and why some are calling this
a PR stunt for right wing politics.
There was this controversial figure.
Everywhere he went,
people challenged him.
The message is stark
arresting and backed by $100 million.
That's how much organizers say
is behind this campaign to market
Jesus as a patient,
loving, inclusive cure
for our divisive times.
With the tagline He Gets US.
Jason Van der Ground.
We're trying to unify the American people
around the confounding love
and forgiveness of Jesus.
The campaign website is filled
with phrases saying
Jesus called out the toxic
religious and political systems.
Led the protest against the walls
that divide us
and broke the chains
that held women in bondage.
Merchandise declares
Jesus was a refugee and an immigrant.
At first blush,
it can all read like a stand
against radical right wing politics
and related divisiveness.
But the campaign pointedly
says this is not an attack on anyone.
It is an outreach to young Americans
whom polls show
are abandoning
Christianity and other faiths
at a historic pace.
A lot of times
when people look at Christianity,
they see it as much more unfortunate
of hypocrites.
Full, judgmental, kind of discriminatory.
Ad The fact that he gets us
is funded
by anonymous donors
acting through a Kansas
nonprofit
link to staunchly conservative causes.
And it raises alarms for some skeptics,
such as Chrissie Stroup,
a former evangelical
who now reports on religion.
I believe he gets his campaign is a PR
effort and website
strategically developed
by right
wing evangelicals
to rope people in with inclusive
sounding messaging
and get them plugged in to local churches
that will
eventually teach them
that to be a Christian means to
support right wing politics
On top of that, this whole
big money marketing of Jesus
just makes some Christians uneasy
so take it how you will that he gets.
His campaign is still moving forward.
They plan to release two new commercials
during the Super Bowl
where ad age reports
some 32nd spots are now
going for $7 million a pop.